David is with us in Austin Texas to
start off this hour hi David how are you
hey doing great Dave how are you better
than I deserve what's up hey well so
just start listening to your program I'm
awesome I love what you're doing thank
you and so I was just curious as to
maybe you could help me out work so my
wife and I we don't have any deaths make
about 90,000 a year and so we haven't
really done anything for retirement and
so it's learning maybe you could help us
get an idea of what we should be doing
and how we can best set ourselves up for
success in the future how old are you I
am 33 cool and what's your household
income about 90,000 good for you
good for you excellent all right is your
home paid for uh we have a mortgage it
is 2,200 a month and what's the balance
on the loan and we owe about 220 and
that is your only debt that is it okay
good no car debt no lease no nothing
nothing okay wonderful very good you
done a great job well do you have an
emergency fund in cash of three to six
months of expenses our rainy day fund so
we've got about fifteen thousand saved
up to probably a little swim on a ninety
thousand dollar income I don't know if
I'd carry you three months would it
probably not yeah probably need to beef
that up a little bit would be my first
goal our first thing we teach people are
what we call our baby steps which is the
process to building wealth baby step one
is save a thousand dollars you've done
that too is be debt-free everything but
the home you've done that baby step
three is have a fully funded emergency
fund which financial counselors and
planners pretty much all of us agree
it's one of the few things we all agree
on it should be somewhere in that three
to six months of expenses range of your
household expenses so you know I
probably want that thing up at 20 maybe
25 something like that just in case
something happens and you know you got
that nice pad there then the baby step
for the next step is start investing
fifteen percent of your household income
your case that's around $14,000 a year
okay the best place to invest that is in
a matching 401k
if you have a Roth available you
certainly do the Roth 401k and put it in
good growth stock mutual funds as a
matter of fact all of these things I'm
going to give you I personally put mine
in good growth stock mutual funds I
spread it across four different funds
equally 25% each and I put a fourth in
growth and income which is the more
conservative of the four that category a
fourth in growth a fourth in aggressive
growth and a fourth in international
okay that gives me a good spread and
I've always got something to be happy
about if the markets going up or the
markets going down I'm pretty
diversified in the type of investing I'm
doing that way a Roth 401 K up to the
match if you've got a Roth 401 K you can
and you've got good options in your 401
K you can go beyond the match and just
get all the way to your 15% if you want
to you know up to the between you and
your wife work outside the home she did
not okay so we're just dealing straight
up on your 401 K do 401 K at the office
I don't you don't okay then we skip
that's part of it the next thing I would
do then in line is a Roth IRA for the
two of you you're allowed to put five
thousand five hundred in for you five
thousand and spousal for your wife I
thousand five hundred for her so that's
eleven thousand dollars in to Roth IRAs
and I would spread it across those same
four mutual funds and if you need help
picking those out and learning more
about them if you're new at this
especially if you're new you sit down
with someone that has the heart of a
teacher that will teach you not do it
for you but you need to understand it
that way when you turn on the evening
news and somebody's freaking out about
the stock market going down you don't
freak out because you know what you're
invested in right but if you count it on
someone else's brain to make your
decisions then it's easier to go into
freakout mode it's your job to manage
your money
so if you need some help with that you
can click on ELP for endorsed local
provider on the front page of the Dave
Ramsey comm site and these people don't
work for me but they're who I endorse
for investing and click on the investing
one they'll sit down with you explain it
to you help you set it up you can set up
a Roth IRA as a draft out of your
checking account
once a month you know each of those four
funds can come out and you know go in
you can pick just four if you want even
pick two for you or four for you and
four different ones for your wife if you
want to in those four categories that
gets you to the eleven thousand dollar
mark that's pretty close to your 15% at
thirty-three years old if you do that
the rest of your life and never did any
more let's just put that in for the fun
of it because it's a good example for
everybody listening not just for you
okay so that that's like nine hundred
sixteen bucks a month so if you put in a
thousand bucks a month roughly and we
did that from 33 to 63 that'd be 30
years
if the mutual funds averaged what might
have averaged since I started I've ever
- little over 14% but I let's just say
the average 12% I haven't had done that
good in the last ten years it's more
like eleven and eleven percent in the
last ten years okay on mine but you know
that it's not rocket science to find it
somewhere in there so using a 12% figure
um let's see here that if you did that
for thirty years never did anything else
I did something wrong alright I'm going
to put it all in here again cuz I'm
putting in a calculator while I'm
yakking so nine sixteen is the payment
and then those future value all right
did it did to do I am totally screwing
this up all right driving me crazy I'm
in yeah 360 months it is it is one
percent zero future and sixteen I'm
going to do this now I'm bound and
determined sitting here from 12 million
people screwing this up all right there
we go that's more like it
3.2 million dollars Wow so if you don't
do anything else and if I'm half wrong
you're still a millionaire okay that's
not that so you know you're on track and
here's the thing I'd like for you to do
more than that there's anything else you
can really do unless you have some
self-employment income or
unless you have a 401k or something
start being offered you can just do some
straight investing in the mutual funds
but it'll be taxable as it goes along
the Roth IRA of course grows tax-free
that money there is not going to be
taxed at all
it's a hundred percent tax-free so the
point is is that a 33 year old in
America today investing $1,000 a month
can retire a multi multimillionaire at
the time you get to 65 years old there's
no excuse for people not being
millionaires except we spend everything
we make and you have people haven't done
as good a job as David stuff that we did
a great job with your finances by the
way long before I met you today I mean
to be debt-free everything but your
house make it 90 K and have a pretty
good start on your emergency fund you're
in the top probably five six percent of
Americans right there I mean you don't
really you know just kind of take over
Congress because they can't seem to add
so um yeah it's just common sense but
you're doing it you're actually doing it
you're performing way to go very well
done and you will become one of those
evil rich people if you stay on the
track I teach you about this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show and so you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you